welcome back everybody welcome to this
closing plenary session now before we
get on with a scheduled program I just
wanted to introduce a special guest
professor Frank vill check of MIT who is
the one of the two thousand four nobel
laureates in physics is joining us and
frank ville check if you'd come on to
stage please come join me here very nice
why don't we turn to face the audience
don't turn up do you want to perfect
thank you very much indeed so Franco
gartenberg I'm sorry I couldn't make it
in put on in person but actually in a
way I'm glad I couldn't make it in
person because this is an extraordinary
experience all so you you've been you've
been going around mingling with people
during the drink sessions and the coffee
sessions have you had some good
conversations I've had some nice
conversations and I'm learning to
inhabit two bodies at once there is a
learning curve involved but it's quite
you know at first it feels very strange
and kind of awkward but very soon one
gets accustomed to the idea of having a
distributed intelligence and I can get
it it but I it gives gives me a lot to
think about and all of us should think
about what what news could be made of
this kind of ability 22 Lucayan to get
around could still get to the Louvre or
people can communicate across very
different time zones a lecture could
student as professor could interact with
students in distant places or a doctor
it's just amazing if you could start to
think about the possibilities so it's
very appropriate in thinking about the
future of intelligence to also think
about distributed intelligence
I feel very privileged to be
experiencing it oh how lovely thank you
for being here and we should just ask
where are you in fact what are we seeing
on Cambridge Massachusetts I'm sitting
comfortably in my study at home and but
absolutely but i'm also at the same time
it depends what you mean by me i'm also
in gothenburg here i am cute who knows
where else as well excellent alright so
now since you're here you very kindly
agreed to join the next item on the
program so we've got it you're gonna be
an addition to the next panel which is
love we'll try it yeah well sigh but
before we do that panel we just want
we've been going around today capturing
some video of your thoughts on today's
meeting and so Frank if you turned back
you'll see this on screen if you turn
around and the audience can watch to let
surround the video interesting your
aspect of seeing things that you haven't
seen before because when you study these
kind of things it's very easily get
listed in your own perspective so it's
nice to see other kind of perspective
and nice to see what other people think
and have kind of conclusions I think we
need more sort of intelligent to keep to
make us to keep peace more now are more
intelligent of making like mass
destruction weapons and making wars we
need to be more social intelligence to
give our our climate our our planet safe
and peaceful for every one of us so what
the last speaker said about we haven't
seen anything yet I think that was the
most important part of the thing because
this is part of the evolution and it's
important that we have this discussion
because everything that our develop
could be used in a wrong way so we have
to
to understand that and develop it
together into something good but what we
see here in 10 years back we couldn't
imagine any 10 years ahead that will
even more so it's very interesting
future about these technology well what
I find is really interesting is that
such a wide definition of intelligence
because usually we think of technical
intelligence and I'll active behavioral
point of view which I don't think that
we we sort of think about in in there
are day to daily lives so to speak
intelligence is when you are able to
deal with people and understand them but
you also need the wisdom to the ability
to understand yourself that was really
interesting and yeah I'm swearing thank
you great okay so this is the science
and society meeting and what could be
broader than more all more
representative of what we're trying to
do with this meeting then to have a
session where we bring together art and
science where's it going and so our next
conversation is about that topic it's
called intelligence in the light of art
and science and mayor welcome on onstage
the panelist it's going to be moderated
by max tegmark and we have hi mags and
we welcome back my britt Moser and also
the Icelandic artist olafur eliasson and
you we're gonna have Frank you're gonna
have to drive around back here so if you
could turn around and follow me hello hi
Frank I you can come around the back of
these chairs yeah okay
great that there's your parking space
just warm welcome to come round round
more turn turn in here follow me a
fantastic a little bit more forward care
all set thank you well I'm trying their
comment to your two boys Frank so it's
great it's a great honor and pleasure
for me to be here then we have a great
diversity in this panel not merely in
terms of background with the
neuroscience and art but of course but
also in other ways that the bitterest of
rivals norway sweden iceland denmark
we're all here together and frank adding
cambridge massachusetts to the mix as
well to talk about intelligence art and
science and it strikes me that one of
the hallmarks of artificial intelligence
and natural intelligence that we've
heard a lot about today is the ability
to recognize patterns in the world
around us to study these patterns and
make representations and this is
something which you both have done such
wonderful work with in your own ways
maybe you by studying the patterns in
the hippocampus of rodents to see how
they represent space around them and you
have created such incredibly elaborate
patterns in the art world so to explore
this connection meet them in art and
science i would like to start to ask you
a lot for how has science and in
thinking about intelligence inspired
your art well more generally I've I look
often at times to see what they come up
with with regards how to verbalize with
what on earth's they're doing because
obviously I think what is exciting is
that the subject matter can be so
incredibly abstract and and and on one
side and on the other side do you hear
me Frank yeah because I wanted to get
the body language to
I'm here traction not at all not at all
i'm super focused now but so the point
being so for instance in cosmology or in
deep astrophysics i guess you call it
measuring of deep space I mean so
exciting to see how do they come up with
a terminology that somehow covers the
stuff they turned their trying to
somehow how do they map with regards to
mapping what they're working on right
because it seems that the one of the
limits is simply to imagine what they
are working on and so as an artist I
look into them because you know it's
actually it has to do with abstraction
something really abstract and then they
had to apply words I'll keep are to some
extent models visualizations experiments
on to this very curious because
obviously it's like spacing the
unsurpassable adding space to something
and for that they bring about you know
patterns like the one you are
successfully evolved and and and as an
artist I'm very curious in that yeah and
let me ask the same corresponding
question to you my retina how has art
inspired your science would you say I
think as humans we depend on art because
it gives us I know that you don't like
that that I say that it gives us
pleasure but it's challenging at the
same time and that is part of the art
that it's challenging for it or not
right and I think that is what we see in
science too so when we saw these grid
cells that we discovered in our lab that
you have cells that just expand
throughout the environment and the cell
knows how when it should be silent and
when it should not be silent and it
creates a pattern that looks like a
hexagon looks like looks a lot like your
handbag there yeah with the hex
a hexagonal grid pattern I think that is
kind of of art just to see that and you
have to have this creative mind in order
to see and I think that is what
hopefully we share that we have eyes
that can see something that is right but
I think so so I totally agree but we
also have to see there is an there's a
potential for criticism and this is the
kind of how do we then evolved because
what we make the mistake and often think
is that the grits the patterns the
architected the urban planning society
at a whole we take it for granted as
being natural or static and no not
non-negotiable so the learning in this
is of course once you can understand
alternative patterns as a model you can
also apply that and realize that what we
normally define as reality max you
listening what we normally defined as
reality is in fact a cultural and and
you know very much relative and so there
is a critical potential once you
discover let's face it a new model it's
not that the new model represents
reality it is the critical potential
that that has on to what you normally
take for granted as being real which
then suddenly is not so real anymore
yeah so so that is so exciting with the
brain when we record these cells because
sometimes I've told myself oh this cell
should respond to this environment in
this and that way and then I suddenly
think about this response as what the
animal is thinking and of course that is
not true and also when we discovered
this grid cell we first thought of it as
a universal pattern that was hardwired
inherit but then we see that environment
can change this pattern and the geometry
of the environment can change how this
is expressed interesting yeah very
interesting now I'm the same question
Frank you've thought a lot about the
relationship between art and science in
fact you just wrote this book
where the core premise is that maybe we
should think of our universe out there
as a work of art you want to tell us a
bit about how you see art related the
science of how this inspires you yes I
have a couple of things let me address
the audience he is polite one thing is
that it's naive I think although common
to think of the brain has a single organ
the brain human brain actually has many
different sub units that have different
strengths a lot of our brain is
developed is devoted to visual
processing and we're very good at it and
that's a lot of what art is about a cup
of cultivating that part of the brain
and uterine two hits strengths and
interests science is a lot about kappa
calculating and kind of analytic
operations logical operations on the
world but bringing those two very
powerful parts of the brain into a
common dialog that can be extremely
fruitful there it has been very very
important in the history of science to
have good visualizations and conversely
ideas like perspective where when thinks
logically about the nature of vision and
brings analytic concepts into our have
been very fruitful so that the bringing
the different parts of our capabilities
different ways of viewing the world into
harmony so that they can speak speak a
common language and interchange their
strengths I think is a tremendously
important thing then it also happens to
be a blessing that the world when deeply
understood does embody principles like
symmetry and the idea that you can you
use patterns simple patterns and
repeated forms to generate rich
structure that is appealing but those
ideas of that then those ideas which are
at the root of the scientific
understanding of the world are also
ideas that very much are in the history
of art and in centuries and for our
traditions yeah very interesting do you
have any reactions either of you two
well i think that i think it's it's
healthy to to see if one can look for
systems as an artist i obviously also
keep a door open for the potential that
some artistic patterns that you want are
really not really explainable or
quantifiable you know an artist might
choose to suggest that a particular
handshake is a work of art and whether
that fits into a pattern or not you know
so add can also really be less in
exchange mode so so I so so so with
regards to add in science I think there
is a lot in common but i also think we
should celebrate that there is something
which are not in common and i'm very
interested in creativity as such because
as we live in a culture where they let's
say success criteria is very much the
objectification of creativity what have
you achieved what is the goal of your
achievement what is the goal of the
education we heard about that earlier
whereas a lot of creativity lays really
in the course and the nature of the
process of doing some things through the
bridging and i guess that's so
interesting for science sources they
work that one does bridging the gap
between an idea making a scheduler model
and so on and so forth until the ideas
finally brought into let's say action so
from thinking to action that is maybe
where the creativity is actually
inflicting the world or being touched by
the word and and i think one also needs
to nurture the fact that non squander
fibers success criteria the process is
where maybe we need to look for
art and science potentially also and and
that's why I'm a little generally a
little bit afraid of let's try to map
the principles of saying where is Adam
where's are not because maybe I am or
somebody better than me is about to you
know find out it is not quite where we
hoped to find in speaking don't you
don't know I just want to compare it
with basic science and applied science
so if you have symmetry then you feel
pleasure and it looks so beautiful but
optus also challenging and you don't
know the end result probably sometimes
and that's the same with basic science
we know that there's something very
important but we don't know how this can
be applied in 10 20 years in the future
to human beings and to help humans and
that is the bonus that we got in our
work we just wanted to understand how
these cells in this GPS system in the
brain worked and then suddenly it seems
like these cells are essential when
people get Alzheimer's disease so that's
the symmetry the beauty but we didn't
expect that and we that was not the aim
of our work so I have a follow-up
question for you Maya bit about this the
unexpected one of the hallmarks of great
art is that it elicits a strong
emotional response and the person who
experience is it and I've known curious
when you and Edward for the first time
saw these hexagonal triangular patterns
in your data viewing it is a work of art
you must have been very surprised can
you describe like emotional experience
when you saw this as an artwork what
went through your mind no so so so so i
have to say that this is not only a
dress in my work it's it's a big group
of people that we are working together
with but of course we had this erica
moments and and at different times and I
remember I was getting this computer
program one of from one of ours too
to the malden who made me able to
analyze this and then a sunless sword is
pattern and I said this is mythology and
you can't get this isn't in balaji it's
so regular you can fit equilateral
triangles in and then I started to test
all different kinds of other cells and
they didn't show this and I was just wow
that's the best response you get as an
artist isn't it Wow and we're over time
now so I think that's a perfect note on
which to end this panel I just want to
also say that if any one of you happens
to be at the Nobel banquet tomorrow at
the City Hall install come look up
because you're it it might just so
happen that there is a new star there
that you've never seen before and if see
it it is that might be another
opportunity to go wow thank you so much
I want to make a selfie with you Frank
can I do that just get it on him ok ok
he'll help you baked up oh that's great
i would put it on my Instagram Frank
take a methyl so afraid kiss yeah yeah
after you do yes excellent all right
toasty of our Palace to meet you all
thank you say hi to Betsy thank you ok